imagine imagine what Eugene sledge that
we talked about tonight
imagine what he went through on Peleliu
and the tens of thousands of Marines
that suffered that unimaginable horror
and then imagine
hackworth who he talked about here who
wrote about face assaulting enemy
positions in Korea and he was wounded
over and over again on the line and
still went back for more and then he got
Alan Seeger the poet who in World War 1
went over the top over and over again to
make his rendezvous with death and
there's been thousands and hundreds of
thousands and millions of warriors that
have been in very stressful situations
and faced evil and faced death
much worse than the situation I'm in or
a year in that we might consider
stressful and I even did this when I was
overseas when I was on deployment when I
was a combat leader I was feeling stress
and you know what we took casualties and
it was awful and it was heartbreaking
and but there were other soldiers and
warriors throughout time that had been
in much worse situations Gettysburg or
vicksburg or the Battle of the Bulge and
in all those horrible situations they
proved really that humans can withstand
almost most unimaginable stress which
meant to me that I could to and
you can and and the first step for me is
doing that taking that look to gain some
perspective and then in order to gain
perspective you got to do something that
we already talked about you've got a
detach you've got to detach from the
problems or the stress that you're
experiencing so that you can get that
perspective of them now there's a couple
different types of stress now if it's
something that you can control that's
causing you stress well why aren't you
getting control of it generally it's a
lack of discipline so you gotta have the
discipline to grab control and make it
happen
and when I say you need discipline for
that what that means is these stresses
that you're avoiding they're not gonna
go away if you avoid them so take the
discipline to face the stressful
situation and get ahead of it don't be
afraid of it now there's also stress
that's caused by things that you cannot
control and if you remember talking
earlier about artillery and how horrible
that was and what made it so horrible
was that there's no control over so if
you can't control something and you
can't get control of it you have to at
least embrace what you can and I'm not
saying you're gonna embrace artillery
shelling but I'll tell you what when it
comes to things like artillery or for us
in Ramadi was IEDs and we could do
everything we could do to mitigate that
risk but eventually there's only so much
you can do and you cannot completely
eliminate it but you can't control it so
why you gonna worry about it why you
gonna stress about it if there's
something that's completely beyond your
control
you cannot you've got to detach from
and not let yourself get stressed about
it and on top of that if it's something
that you can't control how can you look
at it in a different light how can you
see it in a way that you could actually
take advantage of it how can you take
that stress and make it into some kind
of a lie you know the the chaos of
combat is something that I couldn't
control but I had to embrace it so I
could try and figure out how to take
advantage of it so when it comes to
stress don't fight it
turn it on itself and use it use it use
it to make yourself sharper and more
alert and use it to make yourself think
more and learn more and get better and
use that stress as a catalyst to make
yourself better